so what does a media do when faced with
a potentially positive dramatic
achievement involving Donald Trump you
find a smaller more embarrassing story
and play it up big call it the split
screen effect for what's been a split
screen kind of morning for him what's so
interesting about today is the
juxtaposition it's literally and
figuratively the split screen you have
to say this is a classic Trump or a
split screen story
what lemmings the split screen
phenomenon overshadowing what's
important to you with something
important to the media that means the
slow awkward diplomatic process in Hanoi
that's meant to enhance the survival of
our country must now compete with a
gossipy spectacle filled with old news
and guess who wins the spectacle that's
what the hearing was for the media knows
every time Trump goes overseas he wins
so maybe they could distract you with
his gratuitous drama and if there's good
news from Hanoi it's just to obscure the
hearings he may try to distract he may
make a bad decision with Kim jong-un or
in any way induces him to overreach to
basically hope that he can pull
something off in Hanoi that will obscure
the other story does the president feel
the need to come up with something
spectacular out of this meeting
something that he can't out as a
historic agreement in order to
overshadow what we're gonna hear on
Capitol Hill today sorry isn't it more
likely the reverse that the hearings are
meant to undermine the summit yes I know
even we took all of its suckers anyway
I've never seen so many people rooting
for failure and Tom Brady wasn't even
playing but it might backfire by placing
these two stories side-by-side it may
create the reverse of what the press
wants what's meant to undermine that
damn Trump actually dams them I mean
they're comparing a dramatic diplomatic
effort that might end a 70 year war with
a partisan tantrum or let's put the
contrast this way we could put an end to
those Falls missile alerts that struck
horror in Hawaii but instead let's focus
on slime ball theater which is protein
powder for the consensus media it's like
comparing a cure for disease with an old
jackass rerun something his store
call with something hysterical never has
something so big been compared to
something so small well maybe not but
it's close all right want for dinner
each major player Trump or Kim jong-un
gets to invite two guests Trump invited
Pompeo and that other guy I can't
remember who Mulvaney yes but one I
think this was a slight to Dennis Rodman
yes no I in fact I think Dennis Rodman
we all have to bite our tongues because
Dennis Rodman turns out you know he was
an important player in that historic you
go back in building relationships I will
say this when I hear chairmen coming say
that what happened on Capitol Hill today
was important because history will
record whether or not we at this moment
stood tall in terms of defending
democracy I don't think it's a small
story and I don't think that just
because these two guys had dinner they
haven't even started their hearings yet
that we should ignore what's going on
here in this country that is of such
magnitude and impacts the presidency of
the United States so that's the way I
feel about it by the way I don't know
what the president's done overseas it
amounts to so many wins I know the first
time he met with this guy we didn't get
much out of it
we've gotten a lot of things whenever he
goes overseas Morgan and he is pretty
good with dignitaries I think this is a
bigger story than this story that we're
covering yes some people have the Super
Bowl I have no kösem a tweak which makes
me really excited you know I think the
major thing and I think we talked about
this a little bit yesterday is the
patience required in diplomacy I don't
think maybe we'll have a big win coming
out of this but I actually can see
what's more likely is another summit
maybe at the end of the year or in 2020
because you have to understand from the
perspective of the North Koreans they
are still at war with us we don't we've
been through many other Wars since then
we don't even I think the average
American doesn't really think about
North Korea but the average North Korean
and leadership thinks that the Americans
are out to get them and are out to
invade their country so that's the
mindset of the person that's at the
other side of the table so I think
there's two things to look for as they
negotiate over the evening
is is there a peace deal which would end
you know officially in the 70 or and
what happens with sanctions the
president has said that he's going to
keep these inking economic sanctions on
North Korea until there is a you know a
consensus on what denuclearization means
but is there some sort of leniency on
the sanctions so that the North and the
South can do more economic partnerships
more business deals together the South
Koreans want that so those are the two
things that I'm looking for that could
that could come potentially out of the
summit tomorrow Dana what are your
thoughts I noticed with youth dressed in
unison with Kim jong-un think that
actually the timing of all of this is
gonna work out in president Trump's
favor from a media perspective and this
is why this Michael Cohen hearing was
going to happen before Michael Cohen has
to go to jail and that is soon yeah a
couple weeks so this he was gonna happen
anyway today was just like the set up
day and the dinner there's not a lot of
news this hearing now is in the books
mm-hmm tomorrow the entire day is
dominated by whatever happens starting
in a couple of hours with President
Trump and kim jeong-hoon and history is
a long arc it is and so that's no one
care about a 24-hour news cycle in the
long run of history so I think
leadership is just doing the right thing
that you think is the best for the
country and then explaining it as best
you can and letting the chips fall where
they may
Jesse I'd like to think if this were
President Obama I'd be rooting for him
isn't it weird you would not but you
know what I mean it but it's like I do
sense there's a lot of people rooting
against world peace yeah yeah I think
they're they're more threatened by Trump
than they are of Kim yeah seem
comfortable and Kim's crosshairs
I do think too for the media to say oh
man these split screens they're the ones
that make the split screen literally
it's their job chest and they
orchestrated the split screen by having
Lanny brink Owen on the same day as the
summit and they should have done it
tomorrow that's rude they're not as
smart as you are and then they said
there are they ponder is Trump going to
do something at the summit's overshadow
the split
screen that we created to overshadow his
summit it's so stupid and to think that
Lani is working pro bono come on he's
still on the payroll of either the
Clintons or the Democrats Lani does
nothing for free it's clear the
Democrats are using Cohen as a weapon to
impeach him and this these prosecutors
in the Southern District are going after
him in order to burnish their
credentials and help propel their
political career by the way if nothing
happens
something still happened because you can
always return to the whatever kind of
cold war you want so if you decide that
you never want to do this then you're
just happy to always be at the mercy of
somebody's missiles so I think this is
what the steps that's already been made
it's pretty good I think there's no
question of that and even people who
have been skeptical like in the national
security community I feel like they have
even been like okay well I'll be a
skeptical optimist yes that's you know
that's the best kind of skepticism
that's know the optimal skepta mist the
mystic optimist skeptical Optive skeptic
skeptical optimists oh you too all right